[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
democratic socialism
[Music]
debate men need to respect women period
so you should respect women i'm sorry i
am a woman so [ __ ] you
if you don't think so
[Music]
[Music]
make it out
sanitizer at the door no toilet paper at
the store
hot such a long quarantine oh damn i
think
i'm gonna sneeze i swear it's just the
allergies
claritin to clear it up please i'm for
the police good lord
[Music]
who's laughing now
everybody was
[Music]
in fact
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chinatown
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
check back that is the face of death oh
boy
[Music]
what
hmm
[Music]
he's got a notification that ruth bader
ginsburg died
could this year get any
you know it's more so that she's
stepping over so we don't we want to be
clear don't buy the fake news
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
tonight on no cops
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump and you
ain't black
it's all about humanity
[Applause]
bastards
you are watching that i and the people
of michigan
all would like to say in unison governor
wentworth you want to conduct that
investigation
donald trump for mishandling kelvin all
right sweetheart you
first michigan i love you god bless
let's make it happen release the numbers
release the numbers release the numbers
release the numbers right why not just
say clearly yeah white supremacists
they should be condemned totally yeah
exactly
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning hey did you
guys steal the election no no we didn't
steal the election
we will have officially surpassed uh the
young turks on the youtube
173 000 with zero registered voters
this is far from over
[Music]
that's not the real scepter he's what
your parents will teach you about when
you get older he's what we call a
communist
and we we had to get rid of them at the
north pole
[Applause]
[Music]
you